TONIGHT.
>> AND FOR THE NICHOLAS HAGUE. .
HE PLAYED TEN
NOW THE GOLDEN KNIGHTS
>> HE WAS R R KICKED OFF
BY FAULK AND
.
AND DAVID PERRON.
>> THAT WAS TIPPED FIRST WAS GO
THE PUCK
THTH
GOING TO BE DENIED HERE.
TO PUSH A BUNCH OF BUTTONS OVER
THERE.
GOT TO APPRECIATE THE
PROFESSIONALIT AND HE SCORES.
LIKE VERY MUCH. WINGCAN.
CREDIT HE'S GOT INTO THE COMING.
AND IT IS NEAR THE THERE
WITH SUNDQVIST.
SUNDQVIST DROPPING IT.
AND A SHOT
WITH .4 LEFTTHE
GOALTENDER.
HE DOES ACUP WINNER WITH
CHICAGO.
OF COURSE, THE BLUES WILL BE IN
CHICAGO ON FRIDAY.AND IT HITS T
SHOULDER UP THE GOALTENDER.
THAT IS
IS A SHOT VIRTUALLY BLOCK DOWN
IN FRONT TO GET IN W, GOT CLIPP
WITH THE MASK AS WELL AND